a besoin de sagesse et pas d'avoir une
espèce de d'agité de l'ego on a besoin
d'une France apaisée je ne redoute pas
grand chose aujourd'hui moi j'ai
vraiment extrêmement confiance dans
cette assemblée dans la capacité que
tous les groupes politiques vont avoir
de débattre j'ai pas de problème à
l'aide de nouveau en campagne j'aime ça
être en campagne et vous pensez vous
pensez que vous pourriez gagner j'en
sais rien je vous dis en revanche le
mandat qui est en jeu aujourd'hui pour
moi c'est pas le mandat des députés
c'est le mandat du Président de la
République c'est sa réforme qui veut
passer à tout prix la concertation
d'abord est-ce que ça vous va
indispensable vous ne pouvez pas faire
une réforme des retraites qui est une
réforme essentielle sans qu'il y ait la
concertation et on grelotait avec 13
degrés au ministère de l'Industrie
paraît-il c'est-à-dire au ministère de
l'Énergie et bien aujourd'hui nous avons
accompagné un releveur officiel de
température est-ce qu'il faut s'habiller
en doudoune est-ce qu'il faut autre
chose qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire non
mais déjà s'habiller en doudoune ça
renvoie encore
je suis désolé de le dire comme ça mais
ça renvoie des gestes individuel c'est à
dire que c'est l'histoire de on ferme le
robinet quand on se lève quand on se
lave les dents on met un pull et on met
des chaussettes en laine et que fait
l'état cette dame est première ministre
que fait l'état la température du bureau
du courrier de l'Hôtel Matignon et de
21,5 degrés Celsius dans le bureau du
chef du cabinet du secrétaire général du
gouvernement il y a 18,9 degrés Celsius
la doudoune là c'est le dernier chic ou
la porte le sèche-lin le sèche-linge et
le col roulé non mais attendez où en est
là où on est
écoutez c'est de la communication à deux
balles c'est devenu ça la politique
nouvelle main courante déposée contre
Adrien catenin sa femme dénonce un
harcèlement de sa part depuis la
révélation de violence conjugale au sein
de leur couple il s'agit cette fois de
SMS envoyé en très grand nombre mais qui
ne sont ni l'Union ni menaçant ça va
être très gênant lundi si Adrien cadenas
avec en plus il y a une deuxième main
courante l'affaire continue il y a une
enquête préliminaire ouverte il y a
comme un feuilleton il y a des faits
très graves qui l'a reconnu dans un
communiqué qu'il siège dans le groupe de
la France insoumise ça me paraît
instrument aujourd'hui il est encore et
député et donc comme député moi comme
président de l'Assemblée nationale je ne
suis pas gênée à ce qu'il siège dans
l'hémicycle une regrette absolument rien
et vous ne me ferez rien à regretter
j'ai répondu en tant que citoyenne dans
un moment où il fallait de la
transparence parce que nous étions
accusés à gauche de ne pas être
transparent sur nos affaires et donc il
fallait de la transparence il fallait de
l'indépendance c'est ce que j'ai garanti
en en posant cette parole Marine Le Pen
Eric Zemmour Laurent Wauquiez Florian
Philippot et tous
rassemblons-nous de gauche de droite
qu'importe c'est pas l'alliance de la
droite c'est l'alliance des patriotes
des souverainises de ceux qui aiment la
France qui veulent la sauver voilà ce
que je vous propose parce que je peux
vous dire que depuis que cette affaire à
sortie je sais plus quand est-ce que
c'était mais c'était hier de jour voilà
quelque chose comme ça et bien vraiment
ma situation devient extrêmement
difficile l'ADN de nous France c'est le
refus de toute union jamais de la droite
et de l'extrême droite c'est l'appareil
est l'air aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est
pas une force c'est pas un atout c'est
un boulet c'est un boulet avec un passif
monumental c'est un boulet en ayant au
travail toutes les promesses faites
alors électorat donc l'appareil et l'air
on en veut pas par contre la force
électorale et les les nouveaux électeurs
quoi bien sûr que les républicains
pourraient s'associer au RN et à la
nupes et voter une motion
pas ma langue en ind les supporters de
l'équipe perdante envahissent le terrain
ils seront presque 3000 sur la pelouse
certains joueurs sont pris à partie
escortés jusqu'au vestiaire la fête
internationale des ballons d'Albuquerque
aux États-Unis le plus grand rendez-vous
au monde il est incontournable pour tous
les passionnés de montgolfière qui en
l'occurrence vous le voyez prennent des
formes plus originales les unes que les
autres une enquête doit permettre de
comprendre les failles dans le
dispositif de sécurité et si la capacité
du stade de 42000 places a bien été
respecté palme de l'économie d'énergie
revenait cet après-midi à l'Élysée 16
degrés 8 relevés chez les proches
collaborateurs du président